bon les gars
aujourd'hui je vous ai préparé
je vous ai préparé aujourd'hui un
véritable petit cabaret
essayer de ne pas rire il ya beaucoup de
vidéos comme ça sur youtube en avez vous
déjà vu une
non avec toi vous regarder youtube
connaissez maintenant tu sais quoi pitch
le concept alors le concept qui nous a
convoqués des gens tous farfelus les uns
plus que les autres et en gros on doit
ne pas rire à tout ces farfelus tri en
gros on va passer un bon moment tous les
trois mais devant cette rue qui semblait
parfois cette drôle volontairement
parfois c'est pas drôle volontairement
tu vois là ça tu pourras plus faire bien
attention
on a bien compris le concept voilà merci
aux gens qui vont venir aujourd'hui nous
divertir ils vont venir la laddh voltige
coach mais sont très proches de nous
enfin si je vous regarde c'est fini en
tout cas moi je suis très chaud pour un
des petits spectacles aussi soyez prêts
on va vraiment en sachet lazio
[Musique]
ce parti
bonjour salut de la magie alors on va
tester quelque chose avant si ça
fonctionne pas on part tient son du
mentalisme et la magie à ces cliniques
sociopolitique hausse voilà les scada
qui ont déjà participé à ça à l'hypnose
bruit parce que moi j'ai essayé alors
moi je ça prouve en contrôler l'appareil
gc ca marche c'est rodez control freak
au caire
on va faire les tests avec vous trois si
on a un qui part bien tant mieux sinon
repartir sur autre chose balesi météo
demain comme ça écarté les deux doigts
comme ceci je vais juste imaginer je
mets un aimant ici un aimant leur pareil
tu vises se disent bien un élément ici à
la team sur galicie non vous restez
concentrés sans aurait seulement sur ma
voix est maintenant les doigts se
rapprochent maintenant de plus en plus
et de mieux en mieux vous restez
concentrés sans la voix et seulement si
on va voir rozeille son sujet puis
d'orienter impérial syndrome ici en
revanche bloqué impossible pourtant les
décoller son col et soudée de plus en
plus et de mieux en un possible porte à
les décoller au contre chelsea mais
impossible de faire 2 et 3
en émoi ici à nous on va faire mieux ça
va chez marc savard schéma doit se
concentrer sur moi et tu vois imaginer
ici deuxièmement comment très très fort
et et doit se rapproche maintenant oui
il reste concentré n'ont pas vu juste
comme ça reste concentré sans vrai
seulement sur ma voix quand je dirais
les mots dormir sera conscient de tout
ce qui se passe mais qui serait dans un
état naturellement très très bien
clément se toucher ce collector bien
mais heureusement devient de plus en
plus et je vais dire le mot dormir là
pour son accident
tu reste concentré sur le voir ici
désolé je veux pas de ça je le vois tu
sois ballet tour et c'est le geste qui
bat kim à fait correct je suis désolé
mais trop c'est pas grave c'était pas
réceptifs mais non mais ça va pas la
tête
mais en vrai en vrai j'ai un port là
j'ai un peu envie de me d'or moi je
pense que ça marche ces trucs là ont le
vrai ils sont pas là gassama champions
va pas on va faire un truc mentalisme
est ce que vous connaissez du coup
genuis janice les paroles bien j'y tiens
tu ferais remarquer jean news.com jean
huss programme blessures quand tu as
envie de vivre donc c'est un peu marcher
jimmy choo pour comme j'y suis car je
peux juste récupérer ton iphone bien sûr
ce qu'on va faire c'est que je vais
faire une lecture de penser pense à une
musique auquel et j'en fais tu là
rappelle dans ta tête alors faisait dans
ton esprit je fais évidemment ne soient
invisibles ans était très rapide alors
vas-y et continuer à croître la france
attache à ta musique oui tu as fait une
recherche de musique ok cliquer dessus
et un talent est allé parole a qui vont
avec oui je vais demander de prendre un
mot 7 8 9 10 lettres peu importe ouais
j'suis là il est bien ce qu'on va faire
c'est que j'ai mille mois de chrono
j'essaie de deviner la musique le mot
auquel tu penses toujours possible au
kenzi hockey dont mot pense à ton nom
plusieurs fois je dirais qu'il ya un eu
hier qu'elle continue à repenser il ya
un air
je dirais qu'il ya un bep et un bébé
earache ya panache
27 secondes et 45 centièmes est ce que
tu penses que c'est possible puisque
savoir capter mots là là ouais bah
lorsque tu me dis non c'est a réussi a
tempêté chose bon à rien de faire
semblant tu sais que
sans moi je le bois c'est le semblant
tac atari com ouais ouais c'est ça c'est
fort pense à la musique sur france 2 oui
parce que claude françois parent comme
d'habitude fort à la très forte que je
vois c'est là
c'est quoi même quand elle est plus loin
tiens bien avec moi
ici va se passer quelque chose tu sens
je sens
la table et bouge là il ya un pied de
table qui vont sortir tu peux tourner
sur
ses talons il se passe quelque chose
avec toi sous le nom mais ça n'a pas de
sens tu as
tant la charge parce qu'on me souvenais
pas en quoi
je crois que je peux penser peut-être
que y'a un truc
ok boya un petit secret dans la table
bravo gains franchement bravo
boutonnat on l'a on n'a pas très bien
démarré début avec l'hypnose et où ya eu
un vrai lâcher prise de ma part et après
il ya eu des trucs fous sur la lancée
surréaliste quand je vois une led bleue
fait franchement très chaud et la table
j'en parle même pas mais la table après
j'ai une idée de comment ça c'est fait
on dira rien je connais fluvial et on va
se le dire ressentir nous à quoi après
et encore une fois je gage envie de
dormir depuis tout à l'heure donc ça
marche contre les états unis à ces
augmentations je veux le redire
d'équipage c'est très simple il ya une
phrase aux tirs on était en même temps
de 3000 euros tour quoi trop mûres ou la
table ouais il fait le dire du sens mais
ça n'empêche elle coûte cher c'est bête
hein c'est pas vraiment le secret du
tokyo mais les gars excuse moi mais
aucun dribble malgré la défaite
3 0
[Musique]
le kop aux courbes
pendant cette série
[Musique]
oh
c'est important
[Applaudissements]
qu'elle voulait peut-être un peu des
détours pour vous aider vous pas vous
aider
je peux faire semblant de télé
je crois que c'est le truc j'ai fait le
plus craquer de tous les autres délires
de rire ils sont très forts attentions
sont très forts mais quand quant à elle
choisi la mauvaise aiguille
j'ai les réouvrir
il va chercher lui-même l'hameçon est
fait par duverne saga j'ai failli et on
laisse béton par
quel point
c'était surréaliste à ses pairs moment
fou comme je n'ai jamais vécu fils mois
les roches de ça que je les maths pour
moi m'ont tellement il ya tout dedans ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est un joueur et c'est
la pépite extrêmes là j'ai pris une
patate de 2,2
de vie
[Musique]
fakir est
une guerre qui c'est qui a ramené un
petit rocher pour celui y est huguette
serge
sadi coleraine
emma la taille de la kids à cette
réforme la vie devant moi
je me buts el hadri
en mode 2-6 6-7 8-6 si cette équipe qui
est impossible de shopping carte
graphique à cause du minage de la poule
sur la vie de ma mère je serais morte
avant que sergio ramos joue pour le psg
[Rires]
n'y a pas de quoi rire
[Musique]
oh oui vous vous souvenez mois on a
tourné dans serge le mythe ensemble vous
savez qu est ce que tu dis vous et on a
tourné ensemble déjà nous faisons selon
serge le mytho juliette souvenez ça ne
fait même pas du tout ah bah alors on
fait des bons souvenirs
bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
évidemment
oui est vraiment riche et évidemment il
est rentré j'ai dit je sais nature quand
même pas c'est notre seul comme tu m'as
vu outre c'était sur astérix et obélix
vous avez tourné oui zlatan ne restait
rien
d'officiel
on l'a on l'a tous sur
des galets
voilà
[Applaudissements]
qui ne s'est pas franchement ces
processeurs joie
bravo
il sait pas et cry merci hugo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
savary gas gas j'aurais pu découvrir
ses pensées c'est pas pire ça c'est qu'à
ses fruits
c'est tombé
5 ou dubaï
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les gars ce moment il n'est ce pas
magnifique en jour c'est le dernier
l'approchait
bonjour tout le monde aux bombes à ce
que vous êtes prêts ouais prêts à vous
connaissez le yoga du rire non bon ben
je vous invitais à vous lever on va
participer tous ensemble à cette
expérience est ok parti propose de faire
connaissance je vais donner mon prénom
et je vais le personnaliser avec un rire
qui m'est propre et l'ensemble du groupe
va répéter le prénom et le rire de la
personne qui s'exprime et ensuite ce
sera à toi et ainsi de suite allez moi
c'est gérald
à
toi moi je m'appelle acquis
salut moi c'est luca luca
salut moi c'est jo
[Rires]
les abonnés y
aller comme moi ok ok double quais et
les lunettes du rire pour voir la vie en
rire
je vous amener à marcher dans la pièce
on aurait juste marché face à la torre
va se poser comme moi ça le regarde
comme vous
[Rires]
allez les kangoo là où j'espère on
aimerait et
allez reprendre notre petit potion
magique comme moi et rés
[Rires]
vous applaudir
[Applaudissements]
vous avez gagné à merci merci c'est
hilarant si ça joue sur le crime comme
techrine gerbe fund to tape une énorme
barre de malades etc mais c'est une
vraie bombe je suis en live mais tu es
le remercie d'avoir j'ai le jeu c'est
vrai que maintenant c'est irrésistible
et irrésistible après on dirait une
secte on a un chaud lapin un show dans
un cabanon d'un show qui fonctionne très
bien tout ce qu'on a vu il ya ça m'a
enlevé johan truc il serait enfin c'est
pareil j'ai très envie mais ça se tasse
technaute 6 et encore
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est du jamais vu ça j'aime tant qu est
ce que tu m'envoies moi j'ai une idée d
arrêt cardiaque
l'expérience est allé battre faut que
vous compreniez que l'expérience c'est
nimp fakir restera number one dans dans
tout ce qu'on a vécu emotionnellement
lui il arrive et il a fait un strike
suit pas vu venir avec son t shirt jaune
et l'immeuble et moi je suis tombé par
terre mais lui les cas il faut le il
faut le casser pour des films mais tout
sera lui c'est un des mecs les plus
inspirantes gilles et j'ai envie d'en
refaire plein c'est hilarant mais tu es
en vrai les gars que tu invites
franchement cela qu'il faut moi ils
m'ont épaté parce qu'il faut aussi noter
que c'est pas facile tu rentres il ya
une équipe technique à nous comme ça qui
regarde on assiste et fait des
représentations
qu'ils y vont à fond chapeau en vrai
chapeau j'ai quand même failli des creux
ya 5 620 kg le prix j'ai failli prendre
sur la foire en petit brunch
donc c'est à toi fred met la main sur
l'épaule pour vous pouvez mon affection
vous revenez quand vous voulez j'ai
passé un excellent moment merci d'avoir
regardé la vidéo et
ouais j'ai faim on a vécu trop d'émotion
d'un et bien écoutez à 13 une prochaine
vidéo mais très bon gars et surtout le
lieu où tout le monde
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais